una disculpa histórica esperada por
décadas el papá francisco pidió perdón a
los pueblos nativos de canadá por el
maltrato que sufrieron en el país niños
indígenas a manos de la iglesia católica
pido perdón por la manera en la que
lamentablemente muchos cristianos
adoptaron la mentalidad colonialista
colonialista de las potencias que
oprimieron a los pueblos indígenas entre
1881 en 1996 más de 150.000 niños
indígenas fueron separados de sus
familias y llevados a internados
cristianos financiados por el estado en
un intento de aislar los de su cultura
algo que la comisión de la verdad del
país calificó de genocidio cultural en
las llamadas escuelas residenciales
dirigidas por sacerdotes y monjas
católicos los menores se enfrentaban con
frecuencia violencia física y sexual o
incluso morían de hambre
pido perdón en particular por el modo en
que muchos miembros de la iglesia y de
las comunidades religiosas
cooperan también por medios la
indiferencia en esos proyectos de
destrucción cultural
sobrevivientes y líderes indígenas
agradecieron la visita del padre
es claro para nosotros que usted escuchó
profundamente en con compasión
que le contaron como nuestras lenguas
fueron suprimidas nuestra cultura
arrebatada y nuestra espiritualidad
denigrada
pero muchos piden más que una disculpa
una compensación financiera la
devolución de reliquias en los museos
del vaticano así como llevar a la
justicia a un presunto abusador quien
hoy en día vio en francia el año pasado
el descubrimiento de cementerios con
cientos de niños indígenas que habían
estado en estos internados puso la
responsabilidad de la iglesia católica
en el radar internacional